المزيد عن هذا الموضوع الزميل خالد
الغرابلي اهلا بك خالد نبدا باهميه
مولدافيا الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لروسيا
سنرى على الخريطه اين توجد مولدافيا الروس
الان هم يقاتلون في الشمال الشرقي
لاوكرانيا في شرق اوكرانيا في الجنوب
وبالتالي ان هيمنوا على مولدافيا بشكل من
الاشكال ممكن ان يمثلوا شوكه في خصر
اوكرانيا لانها تقع في الجنوب الغربي
لاوكرانيا وبالتالي فسيكون هنا المهم ان
من مصلحتهم ان يسيطروا عليها نقول من
مساحتهم شيء وان يقوموا بالفعل هذا شيء
اخر مختلف تماما هم لهم ارضيه لكي يهيمنوا
لماذا لان مولدافيا هذه التي نراها مجبلها
الان
استقلت عن الاتحاد السوفيتي عام 91 ومع
الاستقلال بدات نزاعات مسلحه وخرج
الانفصاليون الناطقون بالروسيه في هذه
المنطقه الحمراء واعلنوا استقلالهم من
واستقلالهم من جانب واحد طبعا لم يعترف
بهم احد في المجتمع الدولي لكن في هذه
المنطقه نحو يسكن نحو
470 الف انسان يتحدثون الروسيه هم مستقلون
عن مولديا الام وهذا واقع موجود ومدعم 92
هناك نحو 1500 جندي روسي موجودين هناك
بصوره قوات حفظ السلام يعني الروس موجودون
عمليا على الارض وهؤلاء قريبون يريدون
الانضمام الى روسيا بشكل من الاشكال خاصه
ان بقيه مولدافيا هم اقرب الى الغرب
انتخبت في السنوات الاخيره رئيسه وحكومه
قريبه من الغرب واصبحت مولدافيا مرشحه
للانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي بعد بعد بدايه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اذا هناك جزء
يريد الانضمام الى روسيا وجزء يريد
الاقتراب من العرب طيب ما الذي كشفته
فحوى هذا الاعلان البدايه كانت مع
زينينسكي قبل اسبوع امام الاوروبيين يقول
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه كشفت او استطعت ان
تصل الى معلومات بان روسيا تريد ان تهيمن
على مولدافيا
على الحدود مع اوكرانيا بعد ذلك بعد اسبوع
تخرج الرئيسه وتقول انها الخطه الاوليه
كانت استغلال المظاهرات التي خرجت الخريف
الماضي للاحتجاج على حاله التضخم وارتفاع
الاسعار في البلاد
والجزء الاخر من الخطه هو الاعتماد على
اناس من روسيا من الجبل الاسود من
بيلاروسيا او روسيا البيضاء بالاضافه الى
اشخاص من داخل مولدافيا لهم خبره عسكريه
لكنهم يتحركون سيتحركون بلباس مدني
ليهاجموا المؤسسات حكوميه وحتى يقوموا
باخذ جرائم بهدف قلب نظام الحكم
اقامه نظام غير شرعي في البلاد لاستخدام
مولدافيا في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا هذا مقالته
البلد طيب هذه التصريحات فيها شكوك فيها
شكوك كبيره لماذا اولا ان مصدر التصريحات
اول ما تحدث عن التصريحات هو الرئيس
الاوكرانيه الذي هو طرف في الحرب ومن
مصلحته في نهايه الامر ان يشعر الاوروبيين
والولايات المتحده بان هناك خطر لان ذلك
سيساعده على حشد القوى الاوروبيه في دعمه
في هذه الحرب ثانيا رئيسه مولدافيا لا هي
ايضا لها مصلحه اولا نتساءل ان كان هناك
خطه اوليه بدات في الخريف الماضي لماذا لم
تتحدث عنها مسبقا تتحدث عنها اليوم فقط
حديث رئيس الاوكراني ثانيا هي لها مصلحه
ايضا في الاجراءات التي طلب الان هي مررت
مشروع قانون يسمح لها باتخاذ ما يلزم من
الاجراءات هناك حركه من الغضب في الشارع
في مولداريا لان الروس خفضوا الغاز الى
النصف الذي كانوا يقدمونه الى مولدافيا مع
ضرب اوكرانيا اصبح هناك مشاكل في الكهرباء
في مولدافيا من افقر دول العالم التضخم
وصل الى 30% ربما الاجراءات الامنيه تساعد
على السيطره على الامور هذا اولا ثانيا
ربما يساعدها ايضا على تسريع عمليه
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بالقول ان
هناك خطر روسي عليكم ان تساعدوننا بان ان
تسرع عمليه الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
ثالثا من الناحيه العسكريه يصعب الان لو
كانت الامور في بدايه الحرب عندما بدا ان
روسيا مهيمنه لحد ما على الوضع كنا من
الممكن ان نعطي الكثير من المصداقيه الى
هذه الروايه لكن اليوم عندما نرى ان
القوات الروسيه تجد صعوبه بالغه في التقدم
في الشرق
نتساءل كيف يمكن لروسيا التي بالكاد
تستطيع ان تتقدم في بخمت ولم تنهي المعركه
هناك ترسل لن تكون الاف تحتاج الى عشرات
الالاف من الجنود لكي ترسلها على الحدود
الغربيه لاوكرانيا على حدود رومانيا حلف
الاطلسي الاطلسي وتحتاج طبعا الى غطاء من
الصواريخ والدبابات بعيده تماما عن الام
روسيا وبالتالي خطوط الامداد عسكريا تبدو
الامور معقده للغايه وان كان هذا هو جزء
من تحضيرات حرب الربيع يبدو لتحضير متاخر
للغايه لا يوجد ما يشير الى ان هناك اي
تحرك عسكري روسي لارسال قوات الى هناك
رابعا وهذا في غايه الاهميه انه عندما سئل
الجانب الامريكيه عن مدى مصداقيه هذه
الروايه قال انه لم يتاكد او لم يحصل على
معلومات من مصادر مستقله الامريكيون هم من
اكثر اجهزه الاستخبارات العامله في هذه
المنطقه ولو كان هناك معلومات بهذا الشكل
لن ينتظروا ولن يبحثوا عن مصادر مستقله
كانوا هم
يعرفون هذه المعلومات وكانوا يقولونها
بشكل صريح لكن الحديث على انهم لم يحصلوا
على هذه المعلومات يؤكدوها من مصادر
مستقله يبدو كنوع من التكذيب بشكل
دبلوماسي بشكل دبلوماسي جدا شكرا جزيلا لك
خالد الغربي